(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Ever think
of how many breaths of air
you take in a day?
It's a lot, like 20 thousand,
give or take a few.
All day, all night, our bodies are at work
bringing in the good (bell dings)
and kicking out the bad (buzzer sounds)
But as important as this
is to our very existence,
there's still a lot that
many of us misunderstand
about what's really in our air.
(upbeat music)
- Most people don't know very
much about air pollution.
We don't sort of, see
this invisible connection
between that pollution and
very real health problems.
(man coughing)
I'm Beth Gardiner, I'm an
environmental journalist
and author of the book
"Choked, Life and Breath
in the Age of Air Pollution."
(pages flipping)
(bell dings)
Air pollution is killing
millions of people around the world.
The World Health Organization estimates
seven million annually,
and causing a long list of illnesses.
(keyboard clicking)
(somber music)
Air pollution affects almost every
biological system in our bodies.
Increased rates of air pollution
are linked to higher
rates of heart attacks,
of strokes, of premature
birth, of multiple different
kinds of cancer, of Alzheimer's disease,
and cognitive problems in kids, diabetes
and obesity and the list just
goes on and on and on and on.
The pollutant that scientists
have really honed in on
in recent years as the most worrying
is called particulate pollution.
- [Scientist] If this man
is continuously exposed
to this sort of atmosphere,
then there will be
a buildup of these particles.
- It's tiny particles called PM2.5.
They are less than 2.5 microns in diameter
that is about a 30th of
the width of a human hair.
PM2.5 and even smaller ones,
which are called ultra fine
are so small that they
can actually penetrate
deep down into the lungs,
all the way into the tiny
little sacs called alveoli,
Where the air within our lungs
crosses into the bloodstream.
Once they're in the bloodstream,
they can travel all around the body
and impact all of our different organs.
(keyboard clicking)
A lot of people really
associate air pollution
with cities, that this
is an urban problem.
Air doesn't know any boundaries,
it doesn't stop at the city limits.
These tiny particles can actually
travel thousands of miles.
There are a lot of different pollutants
mostly related to burning things.
Oil and gas and diesel and
wood and coal and garbage.
(mellow country music)
Agriculture is another, unexpected,
but pretty significant
contributor to air pollution.
The different chemicals that come off of
fertilizers and manure combine in the air
with other pollutants.
- [Vintage Cartoon Narrator] And the smell
can be a real nuisance to your neighbors.
So it's a lot of different
things in the air.
Whether you're living
close to a factory farm
or hundreds of miles away from them.
(birds singing)
But this is not a problem
that is equally distributed.
It's not just cities,
it's where you're going to end up living
if you have lower housing costs.
The neighborhoods that
are most heavily impacted
very often are poorer,
people of color, immigrants,
people who lack the ability
to move somewhere cleaner.
Those tend to be the places where
these really polluting
facilities get sited.
So this is really a problem
that tracks very much
with the fault lines
of economic inequality
and racial injustice.
(keyboard clicking)
(happy music)
When we talk about
environmental challenges
and how to fix them, the conversation
often gets really, really
focused on what it's gonna cost.
(cash register dings)
In terms of public health, productivity,
longer life spans, the
benefits in dollar terms
of cleaner air are dozens of
times greater than the costs.
But of course, the costs have to paid
up front by industries.
And the benefits are reaped
years later across society.
(presidential music)
The United States has historically been
an impressive global air
quality success story.
Because of this very strong,
very innovative law, the clean air act.
Supported, by the way, by both
Democrats and Republicans.
That started with getting
lead out of the air.
Lead was in gasoline.
There's 70 percent less
pollution in the air
than there was in 1970
because of this law.
The lesson that comes from that
is that we know what works.
This is not an impossible problem.
Science based regulations
that prioritize public health works.
All these illnesses and death,
it can feel sort of overwhelming.
But it's also quite inspiring
when you look at what
has been achieved so far.
- [Narrator] There are
also innovative solutions
in the works to drastically
reduce pollutants
before they even get into our air.
Bold ideas that take us
away from burning things,
to cleaner energy.
Re-imagining urban spaces
that are friendlier to
bikers and pedestrians.
And shifting to electric vehicles
to get us everywhere else.
That kind of ingenuity
might be the difference
between breathing dirty air now
(man coughs)
or truly fresh air in the future.